forget Wonder Woman's golden lassos and
Tiaras the Amazon of ancient myth were
much more gruesome than any DC Comic
heroin according to the Legends they
were man-hating baby killing war
machines who cut off their own breasts
just so they could shoot their arrows
better Amazon were the Fearsome worthy
opponents that male Heroes had to defeat
to prove their battle prowess but were
these warrior women even real images of
fiercely independent Amazons could be
found on countless vases sculptures and
buildings from Antiquity yet over time
they faded into myth along with the
dryads and centaurs Scholars have
debated their existence for decades but
recent archaeological discoveries might
have finally solved this
[Music]
mystery TV shows like Xena Warrior
Princess and Comics like Wonder Woman
paint a seemingly contradictory picture
of Amazon's as terrifying but attractive
isolated from the world but still
compassionate enough to Aid those they
deem worthy modern media also gives the
distinct impression that Amazon were
merely figures of Fantastical myth these
depictions surely wouldn't have sat well
with ancient Greek writers who saw
Amazons as very real but savagely
brutish people the oldest surviving
written mention of the Amazons can be
found in Homer The Iliad penned around
700 BCE a time when the boundary between
myth and history was so fuzzy it was
almost non-existent the ilad tells the
story of the Trojan War which supposedly
happened 5 centuries before Homer's time
though mod archaeologists are skeptical
that a war of quite that scale actually
happened the way Homer described still
the Amazon's presence in the story
suggests that they were in the Greek
cultural Zeitgeist as far back as the
Bronze Age recent findings from grave
sites in parts of Russia and Ukraine
have Scholars thinking that his
descriptions of the warrior women may
have also been exaggerated but first
let's take a closer look at how Amazon
have been depicted in literature and art
the great Heracles was rumored to have
fought the Amazons and emerged
Victorious during the the ninth of his
12 famous labors the Amazon queen
hippolita wore a leather girdle or belt
that was supposedly gifted to her by her
father Aries for being her people's
fiercest fighter King Urus who assigned
Heracles his labors had a daughter who
coveted hippo's belt so Heracles was
sent to retrieve it he sailed with a
small Armada across the Black Sea to the
Amazon's distant and mysterious Homeland
when he arrived Hippa agreed to give him
the girdle without Bloodshed but the
goddess Hera had other ideas she
convinced the Amazon that their Queen
was in danger so they attacked Heracles
forces hippolita was struck down in the
ensuing battle and Heracles took her
belt back to Tyran and its greedy King
despite his many impressive opponents
the moment where Heracles defeats
hippolita is one of his most off-
depicted labors In classical art what a
convenient way for artists to uphold
male heroism while simultaneously
reminding women what can happen if they
stray from their designated roles in
other later versions of the story either
Hippa or another powerful Amazon named
antio was stolen away to Athens to be
king thesis's bride the Amazon besieged
Athens to bring her home but were
ultimately defeated by this Mighty city
state this battle known as the Amazon
macki is featured on the west side of
the Parthenon in Homer's epic poem and
other accounts of the Trojan War the
Amazons were led into battle by their
Queen penes to fight for Troy after
their hero Hector was slain by Achilles
pes's motivation for joining the war
effort is unclear perhaps she was
repaying a debt to her old foe prium the
last king of Troy or maybe she and her
Army were paid mercenaries hired by a
desperate Monarch some say she was
seeking retribution through glory for
murdering one of her fellow Amazons
whatever her reasoning the story of
Amazons in the Trojan War ends much like
every other Greek tale featuring these
fearsome Warriors they fought with
enough bravery and skill to diminish the
Greek ranks but not enough to turn the
tide of War Queen pesy herself was
eventually slain by the Greek hero
Achilles who According to some writers
like arcanus of molus fell in love with
her beauty after her helmet was removed
in death you're a worthy opponent but no
match for the great Achilles I think I
can handle a little boy talks about
himself in the third person who are you
you're weak you're despicable you're
disgusting you're beautiful oh no what
have I done I love you my Amazon
queen but wait don't I also love
patrickus why can't these writers just
make up their minds in this story the
Amazon serve as little more than
convenient plot devices designed to
bolster the reputation of Greece's
military and give their greatest hero a
sharp but romantic Edge thanks to
misogyny and the fact that no writing
survived from anyone who clearly fit the
Amazon description these stories were
dismissed as obvious fiction over the
next two Millennia the Fearsome Amazon
were written off as Pro Athens
propaganda or reim as beardless male
foreigners who the Greeks mistook for
battle warn women that is until a Swiss
law professor named Johan bin published
a paper in 1861 making the radically
feminist claim that Amazon were more
than just myth and that early humans
were naturally matriarchal before the
disease of patriarchy set in but there
was no proof of the Amazon's legitimacy
until the 1970s when genetic testing
technology made it possible for
archaeologists to accurately determine
the sex of ancient s because despite
what some corners of the internet claim
you cannot tell the sex of a long
deceased person just by looking at the
shape of their skeleton in the 1940s
archaeologists uncovered hundreds of
burial mounds called Kens in the great
steps of Eastern Europe and Central Asia
a region of dry open grasslands to the
northeast of Greece the kirens were left
around the 5th century B.C by the Myriad
nomadic tribes famous for their horse
handling known to the Greeks as cians
thians or catian hey boss I found a
grave site what's in it a bow some
daggers a Qui piece it's a male warrior
do you want to look at the actual
remains first oh no that'd be silly what
can those bones tell me that the weapons
in my origin oce agenda roles
cannot originally the archaeologists
assumed the bodies buried with weapons
were all male because well of course
they did 2500 years after Homer and our
scientists still couldn't imagine a
society that allowed let alone encourage
their women to fight but the genetic
testing revealed that onethird of the
Kens were Eternal resting places for
female warriors buried with weapons
armor and evidence of battle wounds just
like the men suddenly the puzzle pieces
started falling into place most myths
have a kernel of Truth in them if you
know how to look for it and this
archaeological evidence was the
magnifying glass Scholars had been
waiting for Adrian May a folklorist and
historian who literally wrote the book
on separating Amazon fact from fiction
beli cian women were the real world
inspiration for ancient Greece's
mythical opponents early artistic
depictions of the Amazon even showed
them wearing cian fashion there has
never been evidence of an all female
Society of Warriors across the Black Sea
who modify their chests and murder their
male children but we do know that the
cians were active and roaming near the
Black Sea by 900 BCE by the time Homer
wrote The Iliad Greeks interacted with
cians regularly and it's not hard to
imagine how they could have invented
such monstrous figures by embellishing
some of their Northeastern neighbors
more unfamiliar traits Homer was an
author trying to write a memorable story
after all the reality of Greek
mythology's favorite war girlies is much
more mundane the great steps are a harsh
environment with few resources so the
cians had to travel and fight to survive
this bred a culture where girls learn to
ride their prized horses and shoot their
Innovative bows just like the boys did
still many of the men were likely to
have died during hunts or raids giving
the impression that there weren't many
of them around the myth about Amazon's
killing or abandoning their male
children could have Arisen from the
common nomadic practice of fosterage
where a family leaves their son with a
neighboring tribe for safety education
or to strengthen an alliance it was also
a convenient way for the Greeks to
support their false claim that Amazon
shunned all men oh and that myth about
their chess that one is just flimflam
from the 5ifth century b.c. so-called
historian elanos was trying to derive
the meaning of the word Amazon by using
Greek Roots even though it wasn't a
Greek word he claimed it meant without
breast but Amazon were almost never
shown with this particular adaptation in
art and even his contemporaries
dismissed his idea as absurd the true
origin of the word Amazon remains a
mystery so it seems that the brutal
misandrist Amazons of lore didn't really
exist but they were caricatures of a
real culture remarkably different from
ancient Greece one where women weren't
relegated to prim and proper domestic
roles consider me disappointed then that
Greek writers didn't include some of the
coolest and most deviant aspects of cian
culture into their monstrous myths like
the Abundant tattoos or the fact that
most of them carried hemp burning kits
in their travel packs most of the world
was fooled by the Amazon's descent into
myth but there's a tiny island off the
coast of turkey that still honors the
memory of the real Amazons women of the
Eurasian nomadic tribes who fought with
just as much bravery and skill as the
men this auxu Festival on garison island
is celebrated every May and heavily
features the sacred humza stone which
locals believe was woried by the Amazons
who lived there Millennia ago we can
learn so much from Garrison Island about
the power of local memory imagine how
different the last 2,000 years might
have been if we had all remembered that
women can fight ferociously enough to
give demigod Heroes a run for their
money in even the most biased stories
unlike Homer we can't change history
through our embellishments but moving
forward we can all embody more of what
Adrien mayor calls the Amazon Spirit
essentially this is the the belief that
women are equal to men in Courage and
skill you know the very message that
characters like Wonder Woman and Zena
were created to convey now it's time for
the next Pantheon pick and I'm excited
to bring some Amazon Spirit to our
Utopia with hippolita yes yes I feel
like our Utopia needs some leadership
energy and uh it doesn't have to be a
monarchy we can choose whatever type of
government we want but we need someone
who can lead the people and if that
person can also defend against any um
incoming rids then that's that's great
added bonus I think that's a great pick
and I like the idea of taking almost
like a demigod or someone more human and
adding them cuz what's Utopia without
diversity exactly I love
it so that's our Pantheon pick for this
episode But be sure to tune in for the
rest of the season because we will be
picking a new deity at the end of every
episode and next time it's Dr Z's turn
to pick I can't wait to see what you
think with Dr mck
mck I got to go Dr M oh my God you
almost did it to M Dr M Dr
m